indien verbrennt seine dämonen um die
vergangenheit zu vergessen
in ihren bank um eine weitere welle zu
verhindern müssen 1,4 milliarden
menschen geimpft werden
indien hofft touristen sollen endlich
wieder kommen an die paradiesischen
strände und die weltberühmte bauwerke
doch kann das land seine bösen geister
vertreiben
schafft indien das comeback nach der
korona katastrophe
[Musik]
das taj mahal indiens wahrzeichen ein
symbol aus tausendundeiner nacht
sehnsuchtsort für menschen aus aller
welt knapp 15 millionen kamen jedes jahr
hierher vor corona jetzt ist es nur noch
ein bruchteil
bei unserem besuch begegne ich nur
indischen touristen seit anderthalb
jahren waren hier kaum ausländer
dementsprechend sorgt unser besuch für
aufsehen alle erzählen mir wie
dramatisch die korona pandemie ihr leben
verändert hat wie sie hoffen dass das
schlimmste überstanden ist
[Musik]
ein paar straßen entfernt lebt und
arbeitet an sagt matt seit 46 jahren
verkauft der kleine miniatur taj mahals
der selbst herstellt doch nun steht er
kurz vor dem ruin
corona hat meine arbeit komplett zum
erliegen gebracht
bis heute geht gar nichts seit 22 märz
die ausländer kommen aber die brauchen
wir zum überleben
40 bis 50 von diesen miniaturen hat er
früher jeden tag verkauft doch indische
touristen interessieren sich nicht für
so was nur besucher aus europa den usa
china
deshalb musste ansatz mit sich was
einfallen lassen er setzt jetzt auf
sicherheitskräfte als kunden und andere
warensortiment
sehen sie jetzt habe ich sogar so etwas
hier im angebot
ja teil von einer polizeiuniform zb
diesem polizei gürtel und das hilft
ihnen zu überleben
das wird uns über wasser
ahmed zeigt uns wo er und seine familie
wohnen direkt hinter dem geschäft sein
haus die verhältnisse sind einfach sechs
menschen leben hier zwei töchter zwei
söhne seine frau und er vor corona
hatten sie ein gutes leben erzählen sie
mir ein jahr hat das ersparte gereicht
wir haben kein geld mehr wir sind pleite
wir haben gerade mal genug zu essen und
das auch nur wegen der gnade gottes und
trotzdem zählt sich die familie zu den
glücklicheren in indien denn immerhin
ist niemand corona gestorben
[Musik]
anders in diesem bitter armen vor ort
von delhi
das virus hat hier unerbittlich gewütet
[Musik]
abstand halten hygiene lockdown all das
ist hier nicht möglich
[Musik]
wir treffen banti band ist 15 jahre alt
und seit corona vollwaise sein vater
starb als er noch klein war und seine
mutter fiel der zweiten welle zum opfer
ich weiß nicht wie es genau passiert ist
sie war arbeiten als sie wieder zurück
gekommen ist hat sie gekocht und ist
schlafen gegangen doch dann hat sich ihr
zustand ganz schnell verschlechtert und
sie ist gestorben
bantis arm schmerzt in der schule ist er
zusammengebrochen hingefallen die wunde
heilt nur langsam ich sehe wie es band
die mit nimmt vom tod der mutter zu
reden dass ein kamerateam da ist erregt
aufmerksamkeit im viertel zu viel für
band i wir ziehen uns in seine winzige
hütte zurück wie es jetzt weitergehen
soll weiß er nicht das einkommen seiner
tante die nebenan wohnt reicht bei
weitem nicht aus sie haben kein fließend
wasser nur ab und zu ein bisschen strom
er hat angst dass er die schule
abbrechen arbeiten gehen muss doch er
will die hoffnung nicht aufgeben
ich will mich in der schule anstrengen
und weniger rumhängen
ich weiß nur dann werde ich es zu etwas
bringen
ich will den namen meiner eltern ehre so
dass sie stolz auf mich sind
corona weisen die band die in die ließ
armenviertel gibt es sie zu tausenden
ohne einkommen und ohne perspektive
kaum ein land der welt wurde von der
pandemie so hart getroffen wie indien
im märz 2020 verfügt die regierung von
premierminister narendra modi plötzlich
über einen lock down
nur vier stunden haben die menschen zeit
alles zu organisieren
hunderttausende die von der hand in den
mund leben geraten in panik sie fliehen
wollen zurück in ihre dörfer
gigantische flüchtlings tracks sind die
folge die polizei ist überfordert es
kommt zu gewalt
tausende werden gesundheitsschädlich
desinfiziert
im mai 2021 verbreitet dann zum ersten
mal delta die indische variante des
virus ihren schrecken die
intensivstationen kollabieren der
sauerstoff knapp die krematorien
überfüllt
indien steht am abgrund knapp eine halbe
million tote zählt das land bisher
offiziell die dunkelziffer aber ist wohl
weit höher
wie hat dieses corona trauma das land
verändert das möchte ich von aaron da
tiere wissen die schriftstellerin gehört
zu den bekanntesten stimmen des landes
für ihre bücher über indien wurde sie
vielfach ausgezeichnet
sie empfängt mich in ihrem arbeitszimmer
hat die pandemie in delhi hautnah
miterlebt how to the city that the
country is wie traumatisch ist es wenn
sie sehen dass ihr im land
sprichwörtlich die luft zum atmen fehlt
es ist ja eigentlich wie eine metapher
aber die wurde plötzlich
realpolitisch wie sozial keine luft zum
atmen mehr das war plötzlich die
realität und dann wurden die leute auch
noch von der regierung brutal behandelt
fast wie als ob sie staatsfeinde wären
die regierung hat nicht anerkannt dass
das land traumatisiert ist und sie
wollte auch keine fehler eingestehen
arundhati roy kritisiert die regierung
modi für ihr missmanagement
das habe so erzählt sie mir den corona
kollaps noch verstärkt
indien ist weltweit bekannt als
ursprungsorte delta variante denken sie
dass jetzt viele menschen angst vor
indien haben vor allem die touristen
es herrscht so viel angst weil wir so
wenig über die folgen des virus wissen
wer hat antikörper welcher impfstoff
funktioniert wie gut gegen die
verschiedenen varianten
ich glaube deswegen zögern sehr viele
leute zu reisen es wird lange dauern
bevor sich alle wieder ohne sorgen und
frei bewegen werden
auch ingo spüren sie dass ausländische
touristen noch zögern zu kommen die
strände gehören zu den schönsten auf dem
indischen subkontinent
jahrzehntelang kam europäer hierher um
zu überwintern
jetzt erst seit anderthalb jahren
trotzdem herrscht bei den einheimischen
am strand eine ausgelassene besondere
stimmung morgen ist das lichterfest
diwali die vorfreude kann ich überall
spüren
am straßenrand sehen wir vor vielen
häusern riesige monster es sind
selbstgebaute figuren aus pappmaché
ingo laufen die vorbereitungen für die
nacht der dämonen
wir besuchen familie penteker
über 20 personen warten gespannt darauf
dass er hier endlich fertig wird nur die
augen muss er noch bemalen
wir nennen das nakasone wenn wir den
acker so dämonen töten beginnt die wally
am ende der nach zünden wir ihn an und
dann beginnt es
in goa feiert man an diwali den sieg
christmas über diese kreatur
stellvertretend für das böse in der welt
in der pandemie bekommt das alles eine
ganz besondere bedeutung
diese kreatur hat irgendwie auch etwas
mit corona zu tun der nakasone dämon
kann auch das virus symbolisieren viele
leute sehen das so und wenn wir ihn
anzünden ist es so als würde corona mit
ihm verbrennungen
eigentlich arbeitet sehr viel eis
künstler verkauft bilder im touristen
doch im moment ist er arbeitslos jetzt
hat er all seine zeit in diesen dämonen
gesteckt 15 tage hatte daran gearbeitet
endlich ist er fertig und alle sollen
ihn sehen dennoch kopflose dem mond muss
vor das haus
keine einfache aufgabe
am ende kommt das wichtigste der kopf
geschafft
doch plötzlich fällt der narr kazur in
die stromleitungen das ganze fest steht
auf dem spiel mit vereinten kräften
schafft es die familie den dämon zu
retten
bis zum frühen morgengrauen wird der
narr kazur jetzt hier stehen damit in
alle bewundern können
wir verlassen die familie und werden
zurück sein wenn sanitäter kazur im
morgengrauen den flammen übergibt
eigentlich sollten den kurs schon seit
15 oktober wieder die charter maschinen
aus großbritannien russland und israel
landen doch touristen treffen wir kaum
viele hotels haben noch geschlossen
auch bei familie borges hat noch kein
tourist aus dem ausland gebucht
vater michael und tochter durch ihn
betreiben das hotel in dritter
generation
jetzt haben sie ihre zwölf zimmer an
indische auszubildende vermietet
so hoffentlich wird es bald besser und
die flugzeuge aus dem ausland kommen
wieder und wenn nicht dann vermieten wir
die zimmer weiter an die auszubildenden
15 monate hatten sie geschlossen
normalerweise würde jetzt die
hauptsaison losgehen vor corona hatten
sich meistens englische touristen hier
einquartiert knapp zehn euro pro nacht
auf den ganzen winter lang jetzt
verdienen sie viel weniger und glauben
nicht dass diese saison überhaupt
tourist nachgekommen die angst vor
indien sei zu groß
doch auch vater michael hat sorge denn
er hatte corona lag im krankenhaus und
will so etwas nicht noch einmal erleben
fünf seiner cousins sind am virus
gestorben
natürlich haben wir angst wir müssen auf
uns aufpassen ich sage auch allen
ausländischen touristen die nachkommen
wollen dass sie eine maske tragen müssen
selbst wenn sie doppelt geimpft sind
seid vorsichtig zumindest noch ein bis
zwei jahre bis die pandemie verweist
dann können wir unser leben wieder
genießen
viele imker wollen so lange nicht warten
in der nacht findet die großen acker
suhr parade statt eng gedrängt und ohne
masken
es ist eines dieser spektakel für die
indien berühmt ist farbenfroh grell laut
verschiedene gruppen stellen denn sie
christmas über den dämonen kazur nach
eine jury bewertet die performance
wir treffen sie hier wieder schaut sich
die parade mit freunden an letztes jahr
ist sie wegen corona ausgefallen
die meisten jungen leute konnten diesen
abend kaum erwarten sie haben so hart
monate lang dafür gearbeitet damit es
wirklich statt von
der umzug wird bis zum nächsten morgen
gehen über 20 gruppen ziehen hier ihre
dämonen durchs dorf
kurz vor der dämmerung ruft unterhielt
sich es sei zeit den dämonen zu töten
mit ein paar feuerwerkskörpern und
spiritus geht es demnach kazur an den
kragen
[Musik]
was wünscht du dir fürs nächste jahr
ich wünsche mir wirklich dass die krone
condomi endgültig zu ende ist und dass
alles wieder normal war so wie es vorher
war
nach anderthalb jahren pandemie leid und
entbehrungen soll es für sehr viel
endlich wieder bergauf gehen das
nakasone feuer ist dafür der startschuss
es dämmert in goa und die menschen
hoffen die bösen geister und auch corona
vertrieben zu haben
für eine bessere zukunft
wie diese bessere zukunft aussehen soll
können wir in buddy konkret sehen in der
sonderwirtschaftszone im norden haben
sich über 1000 firmen der pharma-branche
niedergelassen die pandemie sorgt für
goldgräberstimmung
wir haben einen termin bei panama
biotech neben medikamenten für den
deutschen markt wird hier seit kurzem
der russische impfstoff sputnik wie
hergestellt
desinfektion von fuß bis kopf die
hygiene vorkehrungen sind streng wir
sind das erste internationale
fernsehteam das im labor drehen darf
wir betreten ein anderes indien
futuristisch clean hightech
300 mitarbeiter arbeiten hier rund um
die uhr um den russischen impfstoffe
indien herzustellen doch schon bald soll
sputnik wie auch exportiert werden vor
allem nach afrika und asien
wir haben riesige kapazitäten mit zwei
produktionsstraßen wenn die nachfrage
steigt könnten wir hier auch mehr
impfstoff herstellen auf dosen
umgerechnet heißt dass wir können bis zu
800.000 dosen pro tag produzieren
heißt circa 300 millionen dosen pro jahr
nicht nur für indien
also könnten sie die ganze welt impfen
ja es wäre uns eine freude die wir zu
offen
sichtbar stolz zeigt man uns die
produktion städten
indiens pharmaindustrie habe einen
großen qualitativen vorsprung vor der
konkurrenz beispielsweise aus china
zählt man uns
und sputnik sei erst der anfang so der
ceo nach der besichtigung
werden sie auch andere impfstoffe wie
biontech oder moderner herstellen
ja wir haben schon damit angefangen es
ist schon weit fortgeschritten wir
werden sehr bald neben sputnik auch
diese art von impfstoffen herstellen
das selbstbewusstsein ist jedenfalls
groß hier man weiß dass impfstoffe und
medikamente weltweit gebraucht werden
eine bessere zukunft in lienz so sehen
sie das hier fliegt auch in ihren händen
nach anfänglichen schwierigkeiten ist
die impfkampagne mitmacht angelaufen nur
wenigen monaten vermeldet die regierung
modi die gigantische zahl von 1,1
milliarden impfungen doch in indien
leben 1,4 milliarden menschen und die
brauchen zwei dosen mindestens nur 43
prozent der erwachsenen sind vollständig
geimpft trotzdem sind die
infektionszahlen gering gründe wenige
tests sommerliche temperaturen aber auch
die hohe durchseuchung laut studien
haben schätzungsweise rund 70 prozent
der in der bereits antikörper doch die
regierung geht auf nummer sicher jeder
soll sich impfen lassen
in der stadt ist die infrastruktur gut
die impfkampagne läuft doch auf dem land
könnte der impferfolg ins stocken
geraten am rande der kleinstadt jeweils
zwei stunden von delhi entfernt liegt
das krankenhaus und im zentrum
doktor pankow arbeitet hier seit zehn
jahren und ist in sorge
was sind die schwierigkeiten beim impfen
auf dem land
das problem sind die älteren leute die
wir nicht erreichen
wir versuchen jetzt die menschen über 45
zu impfen das sind in indien zwar nur 16
prozent der bevölkerung
aber je schneller wir diese leute impfen
können desto besser
praveen ist 28
bei den jüngeren wie ihm hätten sie gar
keine probleme sie zu erreichen sagt uns
dr kumar beinahe 100 prozent liege die
impfbereitschaft frau wien bekommt heute
seine zweite dosis mit kobe schielt dem
in indien hergestellten astrazeneca
impfstoff
ich hatte nie zweifel mich impfen zu
lassen am anfang war der impfstoff knapp
aber jetzt haben wir mehr als genug
es bleibt noch viel zu tun und die
furcht vor einer weiteren welle ist groß
gerade deswegen hat paravan kumar für
viele menschen in europa und auch in
deutschland nicht viel verständnis
obwohl die menschen in europa so
gebildet sind konzentrieren sie sich
nicht aufs impfen und in indien selbst
für die die nicht lesen und schreiben
können ist impfen das wichtigste um
gegen diese krankheit immun zu werden
also denken sie indien macht einfach
mehr druck bei den impfungen ja ich
denke auch an all die anderen länder
sollten eine impfpflicht einführen um
diese krankheit erfolgreich zu bekämpfen
die wunden des corona kollaps sind noch
überall zu spüren doch indien wähnt sich
auf einem guten weg im kampf gegen das
virus
ich habe ein land erlebt das stolz ist
auf das was man erreicht hat auf
durchhaltevermögen und den festen willen
das trauma soll sich nicht noch einmal
wiederholen
[Musik]